Célèbre pour ses safaris
et grands parcs à gibier,
Kenya
est moins connu pour son littoral.
Cependant, ses 370 milles de côte
de la Tanzanie au sud,
vers la Somalie au nord,
offrent de nombreuses merveilles naturelles
et aventures de tous genres.
Sur l'île préservée de Pate,
où les bateaux pirates somaliens attaquent encore,
nous commençons notre découverte des nombreux
différents styles de pêche au Kenya.
En route vers l'île de Pate,
nous passons d'abord par Lamu,
la plaque tournante du commerce swahili
conquis au 18ème siècle
par les sultans d'Oman.
L'île de Lamu, tout comme ses voisines,
Manda et Pate,
n'a pas de routes et pas de véhicules.
Les bateaux sont le seul moyen
de transport.
Au large de la pointe de l'île de Pate,
à cinq heures de Lamu
au coeur de l'Afrique de l'Est
deuxième plus grande forêt de mangrove,
Population de Faza et Kisingitini
de 15 000 gagne à peine sa vie
de sa pêche.
Il existe plus de 12 méthodes différentes
pour attraper une grande variété de vie marine.
Baka Ali a 48 ans,
le fils d'un pêcheur d'origine bajuni,
il pêche depuis près de 25 ans.
Comme la plupart des matins de semaine,
béni par Allah, Baka va pêcher.
Baka et son équipage de dix
ne sont pas les seuls
pour tenter leur chance à la pêche aujourd'hui.
Le bateau démarre
tandis que les rayons du soleil du matin
s'élever au-dessus de l'horizon.
Le bateau de Baka s'appelle un boutre.
Cet engin allongé
fabriqué à partir de palétuviers
et équipé d'une voile de forme triangulaire
est encore fait
selon les méthodes traditionnelles
transmis par les ancêtres de Baka.
Ces marins venaient à l'origine
d'Oman et du Yémen
et étaient des hommes fiers
qui a colonisé la côte du Kenya
et l'a baptisé Swahili,
le mot arabe pour la côte.
Quoique bon pêcheur,
Baka est avant tout
un navigateur expert.
Un préalable indispensable dans ce labyrinthe
d'îles, de récifs et de bancs de sable
qui font de la navigation une tâche complexe.
Il doit avoir une connaissance approfondie
des courants changeants,
la hauteur des marées et d'autres facteurs,
comme le Kaskazi d'aujourd'hui,
le vent tropical
ça souffle plus tôt que prévu.
Il a repoussé
son bateau en eau peu profonde,
et à marée basse
dans, Baka doit manœuvrer rapidement
pour éviter d'être pris au piège
et trouver un passage vers des eaux plus profondes
pour repartir.
Baka, Mohammed, Bashir
et les autres pêchent à marée basse
quand l'eau n'est pas trop profonde,
et rester dans le récif corallien qui
les protège des vagues profondes.
Ils utilisent un filet de 150 mètres
attaché à chaque extrémité à une corde de 500 mètres.
Ce type de filet
s'appelle une juya en swahili.
Baka a choisi la zone de pêche d'aujourd'hui.
Il laisse tomber quatre de ses hommes à l'eau
à une extrémité de la corde.
Baka en sait pas mal
sur les nombreuses espèces de poissons
que l'on peut trouver dans ces parties.
Cobia, vivaneaux, cabillaud,
raies pastenagues, barracudas et poissons-chats.
Alors que le boutre navigue lentement,
la corde est lentement
laisser s'épanouir dans toute sa longueur.
Ensuite, le filet est jeté à l'eau.
Les trous du filet
mesurer six centimètres.
Sa partie centrale a une zone en forme de poche
qui emprisonne les poissons.
Il y a deux plongeurs,
un pour chaque côté du filet.
Leur travail est essentiel
s'ils veulent avoir une prise réussie.
Ils doivent garder le filet
d'être pris sur le corail
ou emmêlés dans les mauvaises herbes sur le fond marin.
Le filet va récolter
environ un kilomètre carré de mer,
forcer le poisson
vers le piège au centre.
Une fois les 1 000 mètres
de corde sont en place,
les 11 pêcheurs sont nécessaires
pour ramener le filet vers le bateau.
De plus, aujourd'hui, ils ont
seulement une heure avant la marée montante
et ruine leurs efforts.
Quatre hommes de chaque côté,
l'eau jusqu'à la taille,
lutte contre les courants forts.
Leurs efforts conjoints avec ceux
des plongeurs portent désormais leurs fruits.
L'un des plus jeunes
relie les deux extrémités de la corde.
Les poissons sont pêchés à l'intérieur.
La corde est ensuite secouée dans l'eau
pour empêcher les poissons effrayés
de s'échapper par la partie arrière
du cercle formé par le filet.
Les milliers de mètres de corde
sont lentement attirés vers le bateau,
maintenant ancré à proximité.
Le moment de vérité est arrivé.
Baka et ses hommes,
absorbé par la tâche,
faire un dernier effort
pour enfoncer le poisson dans le piège.
Aujourd'hui, la prise est faible.
Trop de vent,
trop de vagues, eau trouble
et des poissons qui
plutôt s'abriter derrière le corail
ou à l'intérieur des mangroves.
Quoi qu'il en soit, il est temps de rentrer
à Kisingitini, à près de deux heures de route.
Se diriger contre le vent
ne va pas rendre la navigation facile,
et forcera le bateau de Baka à virer de bord.
A Kisingitini,
tous les autres hommes sont pêcheurs.
Le poisson se vend 30 shillings kenyans le kilo,
l'équivalent
de 30 pence anglais ou 50 cents américains.
Chaque pêcheur garde une part
de ses prises pour nourrir sa propre famille.
Ce qui reste est vendu à un
des deux ou trois bateaux marchands
qui achètent la pêche du jour
et gardez-le frais sur de la glace,
avant de le vendre
à Faza ou mieux encore, Lamu.
A Kisingitini, il n'y a pas d'électricité,
ni installations de séchage
ou garder le poisson au réfrigérateur.
Comme il n'y a pas de sources naturelles
sur l'île et pas d'agriculture,
la pêche est le seul moyen de gagner sa vie.
-Ai-je été déçu par la prise d'hier ?
Oui bien sûr.
La mer était trop boueuse
et l'endroit que j'ai choisi était décevant.
Nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup de chance.
La pêche est un pari.
Certains jours sont super
et certains jours nous avons une petite prise
ou rien du tout, mais vraiment,
hier, la mer était trop agitée.
-Maintenant, parlez-nous de votre prise record.
-C'était pendant la saison des pluies.
Nous étions environ 15.
Nous sommes allés dans les récifs coralliens.
La marée était à un niveau parfait.
Ce jour là,
nous avons pêché beaucoup de poissons, 150 kilos.
C'était moins difficile qu'aujourd'hui.
Je préfère pêcher avec une grande équipe,
tous capables et désireux de travailler dur.
Nous aimons attraper beaucoup de poissons
et plus nous sommes, plus nous attrapons.
Non, ce n'était pas si difficile pour nous
ramener le lourd filet au bateau.
Le problème était plus avec la pluie
et le vent qui arrivait rapidement
et fait la mer
extrêmement rude et dangereux.
Nous avons réussi à faire
il revient en toute sécurité au port, cependant.
Pour l'instant, la pêche est mon seul mode de vie.
Si je pouvais trouver autre chose,
bien sûr je changerais.
Que sont Hashim, Haider, Mohammed
et ses amis à la recherche à marée basse
près des bords des mangroves ?
Crabes, coquillages, petits poissons ?
Non, ils pêchent
pour les grandes créatures blanches ressemblant à des escargots
qui vivent dans le sable
près des récifs coralliens.
On les appelle des concombres de mer.
Ils les trouvent à marée basse,
ou dans l'eau jusqu'à cinq mètres de profondeur.
Les pêcheurs
de Mbwajumwali près de Kisingitini
sont devenus des spécialistes du concombre de mer
au cours des 20 dernières années.
Le snorkeling est une méthode assez récente
utilisé seulement au cours des cinq dernières années.
Les plongeurs sont souvent formés dès leur plus jeune âge
rester plus de deux heures dans l'eau,
faire surface, prétendent-ils,
toutes les trois minutes.
Un certain nombre d'entre eux
plonger à des profondeurs encore plus grandes
ont endommagé leurs tympans
et développé des problèmes d'audition.
Aujourd'hui, la pêche a été fructueuse.
Vente de concombres de mer
pour 120 à 180 shillings kenyans le kilo,
quatre à six fois plus que le poisson.
Hassan Ali rachète
et transforme les concombres de mer,
venir directement à la source
pour s'approvisionner.
-C'est vrai, nous pêchons des concombres de mer.
C'est devenu une partie de nos vies.
Pendant longtemps,
personne ne s'en soucierait.
Puis un jour les Japonais sont arrivés.
Ils nous ont tout dit sur le concombre de mer
et nous a appris à les préparer.
Aujourd'hui, on pêche les concombres,
les vendre aux japonais
et ils les mangent.
Tu vois, tu fais un trou
et vider l'estomac.
Vous les faites bouillir,
laissez-les sur le sable pendant une nuit,
puis les faire bouillir à nouveau.
Ensuite tu les sors
et séchez-les à nouveau pendant plusieurs jours.
Alors Hassan Ali éviscère les concombres de mer,
les faire bouillir plusieurs fois
et quelques jours plus tard, après les avoir séchés,
obtient le résultat de son travail.
Il gagne 1 500 shillings kenyans,
environ 15 livres anglaises ou 21 USD
pour chaque kilo de concombre de mer
il revend au dealer de Mombasa.
C'est comme ça que le concombre de mer de Pate Island
trouve sa place sur les tables des gourmets
à Singapour, Shanghai, Tahiti et Tokyo,
assaisonné de citron vert,
lait de coco, sel ou ciboulette.
Bon appétit.
Voyageant vers le sud vers Ngomeni,
autres mangroves sauvages
offrent également une pêche unique.
Le village de Kibaoni
est constitué de groupes épars de huttes
appartenant au calme,
mais des pêcheurs capables
de la tribu des baronnes.
Soso et Samy
pêcher le crabe dans les mangroves
qui entourent le village.
Comme ils n'ont pas de poisson
aujourd'hui pour avoir fabriqué leur appât au crabe,
ils utiliseront des morceaux de poulet cru.
Avec des filets, des appâts et de grands paniers,
ils marchent jusqu'à la partie du marais
qui semble le plus prometteur,
à cause de la marée montante.
Quand la marée est très basse,
certains endroits peuvent être trouvés en train de ramper
avec des crabes de toutes tailles,
tous affamés d'un morceau de viande ou de poisson.
Contrairement aux autres mangroves,
celui-ci n'est pas infesté
avec des serpents et des raies,
pour que les garçons puissent marcher pieds nus dans la boue.
Les deux garçons ont une technique très simple.
Un bâton en bois de palétuvier est collé
dans le fond boueux du fond marin.
L'appât attaché au bâton
sur une ligne de coton
est ensuite jeté à l'eau.
Après une courte attente,
les premières frappes de crabe.
Samy passe à l'action.
Le crabe a mordu à l'hameçon.
Il doit maintenant placer
ses pieds et son corps de telle manière
pour ne pas effrayer le crabe
loin avec son ombre.
La première prise est de bonne taille.
Malheureusement,
la méthode n'est pas infaillible.
Les crabes les moins affamés
préfère lâcher l'appât
quand ils sentent le remorqueur sur la ligne.
Les crabes sont maintenus en vie
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient vendus au concessionnaire
qui achète la pêche du jour
et enfin au chef
qui les cuisine et les sert.
Étrangers et touristes
forment la majorité
des mangeurs de crabe à Malindi,
plus que les Kenyans eux-mêmes.
D'autres pêcheurs sur la côte kenyane
utiliser de grands filets dérivants
appelé jarifa en swahili.
Yunis et son équipage
viennent également de Kisingitini.
Pendant la saison sèche,
de novembre à mars,
ils vivent et pêchent à Malindi,
où un marché organisé
et une plus grande demande garantissent des prix
qui sont deux ou trois fois plus élevés
que ceux de l'île Pate.
La première prise est une raie.
Yunis casse son dard
pour le rendre inoffensif.
Les filets jarifa,
qui sont laissés à la dérive
environ 100 pieds
sous la surface,
sont à une heure et demie de navigation de Malindi
et sont vérifiés tous les deux jours environ.
Les poissons sont sortis
du net un par un.
Yunis et son équipage utilisent également
palangres équipées de 15 à 20 hameçons
appâté avec des poissons morts.
La longue ligne est lestée
avec plusieurs grosses pierres
et abaissé à 100 pieds dans la mer.
Les hameçons sont contrôlés quotidiennement.
Les poissons sont retirés et les appâts remplacés.
La prise d'aujourd'hui est impressionnante.
Raies, vivaneaux, petits requins et silures.
Avant de partir,
le filet jarifa est à nouveau abaissé.
Une bouée avec un drapeau marque l'endroit.
-Alors Yunis,
qu'as-tu attrapé aujourd'hui ?
-Aujourd'hui, j'ai attrapé...
sept requins.
-Sept requins ?
-Oui, sept requins.
Celui-ci est un gros requin,
parmi ces sept.
-Combien de kilos?
-C'est environ 15 kilos.
L'année dernière, nous avons attrapé un gros requin
qui pèse environ 200 kilos.
C'était en mai de l'année dernière.
Quand nous sommes allés voir la longue file d'attente,
et pour la bonne journée,
nous avons attrapé ce requin.
Nous avons essayé de le tirer à l'intérieur du bateau
et parce que c'est un grand,
nous ne pouvions pas le charger dans le bateau,
et nous avons utilisé notre pouvoir
pour le traîner jusqu'au bord de la mer.
En fait, j'aime la pêche,
car c'est mon hobby.
C'est aussi le travail de mon père.
Il était pêcheur, et moi aussi.
Contrairement aux autres Africains, les Giriama,
la plus grande tribu de Malindi,
comme la viande de requin.
Yunis fera
jusqu'à 100 shillings kenyans,
une livre britannique
ou 1,5 USD par kilo.
Depuis que le poisson-chat se vend
pour trois fois moins,
il préfère ramener ça à sa femme,
qui prépare sa recette préférée
en le faisant cuire à la vapeur dans son jus.
Alors que le Kenya
était célèbre pour la chasse au gros gibier
dès le début du siècle,
il a fallu attendre les années 1950,
et l'expédition d'Ernest Hemingway
de la côte de Malindi et Watamu,
avant d'entendre parler de pêche au gros là-bas.
Ian et Kevin sont anglais.
Ils viennent de la région de Portsmouth.
Ian a découvert la pêche sportive
il y a seulement cinq ans.
Au cours des trois dernières années,
il a partagé sa nouvelle passion
avec un ami et partenaire d'affaires, Kevin.
Aujourd'hui, ils se dirigent vers le Neptune,
Le plus puissant de Malindi
Bateau de 280 chevaux.
C'est aussi l'un des mieux équipés
avec huit lignes.
La journée vient de commencer
et c'est le premier poisson.
C'est une belle bonite
qui servira d'appât.
En fait, la journée est consacrée
appâter vivant à différentes vitesses de bateau
pour les poissons de différentes tailles.
Une deuxième bataille commence sous peu.
Celui-ci est beaucoup plus difficile.
Angus, le capitaine de Neptune,
donne le mot, c'est un requin.
Les requins viennent généralement
rapidement sur l'appât.
Cela peut être une lutte brutale.
Le requin peut avaler l'appât
et décoller avec des mètres et des mètres de ligne,
ou il peut hésiter, connaît l'appât
et jouer avec pendant un moment.
Vous devez attendre
longtemps avant de l'accrocher.
Cette fois, Ian l'accroche rapidement.
Le requin soudain
plonge jusqu'au fond.
C'est un mâle pointe noire.
Ian, Angus et Saidi doivent agir rapidement
et gardez la ligne de 50 livres tendue.
Ils doivent empêcher
le requin d'enrouler la ligne
autour de son corps abrasif et le cassant,
ou de plonger sous le bateau.
A cause de ses dents acérées comme des rasoirs
et sa force,
même hors de l'eau,
aucun risque n'est pris.
Angus l'assomme.
Le requin est trop gros pour le sac.
Alors Saidi et Festus
attachez-le le long de la poupe.
- Cinquante kilos ? Cinquante kilos.
Bon poisson, tout va bien.
-C'est ta première fois ?
- Non, j'ai déjà attrapé des requins.
C'est une sensation très drôle.
C'est toi contre le poisson,
et si vous pêchez chez vous,
tu attrapes de très petits poissons
et c'est toujours un plaisir
pour attraper de très petits poissons,
mais si vous venez dans un pays comme celui-ci,
vous avez la possibilité
d'attraper un très gros poisson.
Une fois que vous avez attrapé un très gros poisson,
quelque chose arrive à ton coeur
et tu penses que j'aimerais avoir
un plus gros et un plus gros.
C'est le bogue.
C'est pourquoi tu reviens
année après année après année.
La toute première sensation
c'est quand tu tiens la tige et que tu te penches,
et quand tu sais que tu l'as accroché,
tu as de l'adrénaline
courir dans tout ton corps,
et tu sens ton coeur battre.
C'est une ruée, c'est ça.
C'est bien, très bien.
Sur Neptune,
chaque anneau indique une morsure.
C'est une bonne journée pour le thon et les bonites.
Cela signifie que leurs prédateurs,
porte-épée, ne sont pas très loin.
Voilier, espadon à bec large,
marlin bleu, noir et rayé
existent en grand nombre dans les eaux kenyanes.
Le Kenya est un bon endroit pour les pêcheurs.
Plusieurs records internationaux IGFA
ont été définis ici.
Femelle, marlin noir et bleu
peut peser jusqu'à 1 000 livres,
tandis que le poids moyen
d'un marlin est de 200 livres.
Pas de chance.
Un marlin part
ses marques de dents sur un appât vivant.
A peine sorti de l'eau,
les bonites vivantes sont préparées pour l'appâtage.
Un crochet dans la bouche
et un autre dans la peau du dos.
Puis remis à l'eau.
Nous avons maintenant un nouvel appât.
L'appât vivant descend au fond.
-C'est pour un requin ?
Requin, marlin, karambizi,
n'importe quoi, wahoo, kingfish.
-Celui-ci est vivant ?
Vivant, oui, parce qu'il nage
et c'est un appât très naturel.
Si vous avez un gros poisson
autour comme un marlin ou un requin,
vous préféreriez avoir cela.
C'est le meilleur appât
vous pouvez avoir, alors peut-être.
Parlez d'une coïncidence,
Ian a une bouchée.
Il a attrapé un autre poisson.
-Essayez de le relâcher, d'accord ?
Après le marquage, les karambizi
est déversé dans l'eau pour être relâché.
-Le problème est que vous ne pouvez pas le dire à ce stade,
s'il ira ou non.
C'est le problème.
Va-t-il y arriver ?
Ce poisson pélagique doit continuer à nager
pour que l'eau irrigue ses branchies.
-C'est un karambizi,
qui est une carangue géante.
Il y en a beaucoup par ici,
mais ils essaient
pour en conserver les stocks.
Donc, taguer et relâcher, c'est bien.
-Bien fait.
-Bien joué, mon gars.
Quand tu viens chercher
le verre de vin ce soir,
ta main va trembler.
La haute saison dure
de novembre à mars
pendant la mousson du nord-est,
accompagné du vent Kaskazi
et un courant puissant
venant de Somalie.
Substances nutritionnelles riches
sont recueillis de la pointe de l'Arabie,
transporté jusqu'aux côtes du Kenya,
où ils attirent un grand nombre de poissons.
Un début prometteur pour la deuxième journée.
Kevin a ferré un voilier
qui vient de sauter de l'eau
plusieurs fois et secoua la tête.
C'est ainsi que le voilier
essayer de se libérer
s'ils ne sont pas correctement accrochés.
Il y a beaucoup de voiliers
dans cette partie de l'océan Indien.
Ils pèsent généralement de 65 à 110 livres
et atteindre deux mètres de long.
Mais le plus gros pèse plus de 175 livres
et mesure plus de trois mètres de long.
Ils nagent à près de 50 nœuds,
plier leur majestueux aileron en forme de voile
dans leur dos.
Ils aiment se nourrir
en surface ou à moyenne profondeur.
Contrairement à un requin, un voilier n'est pas tiré
hors de l'eau par la gaffe, mais par son bec.
C'est une façon de montrer du respect
pour cette créature étonnante.
Malheureusement, celui-ci a été accroché
sur le côté et est mort.
-Je pensais que soit c'était gros
ou il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas.
Il a commencé à se battre
puis d'un coup ça s'est arrêté
et ça ressemblait à un poids de plomb très lourd.
Les gars venaient de dire
c'est allé jusqu'au fond.
Nous l'avons donc relevé
du fond des fonds marins,
mais nous l'avons tiré par le milieu,
donc c'était juste comme un poids mort
remontant tout le long de l'eau,
et c'est pourquoi nous avons lutté avec cela.
C'est vraiment dommage,
vous n'aimez pas que cela se produise.
C'est beaucoup mieux
si vous l'accrochez correctement
et peut le combattre,
tirez-le vers le haut et étiquetez-le et relâchez-le.
C'est beaucoup mieux.
C'est un peu la déception
à certains égards, c'est triste.
Je n'aime pas faire ça.
C'est le nom du jeu, n'est-ce pas ?
Cela retournera au rivage
et être vendu au marché ce soir,
et au moins quelqu'un l'appréciera.
Je n'en veux pas trop aujourd'hui.
C'est beaucoup mieux
quand c'est un bon poisson de sport
et ça saute
et puis tu l'accompagnes
puis dites merci et ça s'éteint.
Voilà, c'est ce qui se passe.
La prochaine prise
est une dorade jaune et verte colorée
que Saidi et Festus
ajouter au sac avec le voilier.
C'est au tour de Ian de combattre un istiophoridé
comme un deuxième voilier est accroché.
Celui-ci est solidement accroché dans la bouche.
Ian et Kevin, comme beaucoup de pêcheurs sportifs,
préfèrent relâcher les istiophoridés
s'ils ont été accrochés correctement.
Les istiophoridés sont marqués pour les identifier,
tout comme nous tatouons nos animaux de compagnie.
Le nombre de porte-épée
dans cette partie de l'océan est surveillé.
Cela garantit leur survie.
Marquage et libération
est plus facile à dire qu'à faire.
Celui-ci a mis en place un tel combat
que Saidi n'est pas sûr
il pourra retirer le crochet.
Le succès enfin.
Le voilier est relâché.
-Trente cinq kilos,
et il vit pour se battre un autre jour, peut-être.
Bien.
Neptune ne peut pas jeter l'ancre
à Malindi, à cause de la marée.
Au lieu de cela, il ancrera
nuit à Watamu Cove.
Les pêcheurs retourneront à Malindi en voiture.
-La pêche au Kenya, je pense en est encore une
des rares endroits au monde
qui est pratiquement garanti
que vous attraperez un porte-épée.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde qui
peut se vanter d'attraper un porte-épée.
Si vous voyez les moyennes de la saison
en fin de saison,
ils prennent vraiment
un porte-épée chaque jour.
-Quelle est votre espèce préférée
combattre avec ?
-Je pense un marlin.
Ils sont très excitants.
Ils sautent.
Ils vous donnent du fil à retordre.
Ils ne veulent pas être pris.
Ils sont très difficiles à attraper,
et quand tu en attrapes un
et tu as la chance d'en décrocher un
ou taguez-en un,
il reste avec vous pour toujours, je pense.
J'aime pêcher au matériel léger,
le plus léger possible,
parce que c'est plus excitant.
Vous vous sentez plus du poisson
et ça prend un peu plus de temps.
C'est un travail un peu plus dur,
mais ça te donne une impression
que vous faites vraiment du bon travail.
C'était il y a trois ans,
pêcher avec Angus,
nous avons eu 14 voiliers en une journée.
-Quatorze?
- Quatorze en une journée à nous trois,
et deux marlins rayés.
C'était la prise d'un jour.
Nous avons relâché environ neuf de ces voiliers.
Les autres étaient mal accrochés
et nous les avons ramenés à la maison,
mais c'était le meilleur jour
nous avions là-bas.
Ce n'était qu'un
de ces jours très particuliers
où nous étions juste très heureux
et tout le monde attrapait du poisson.
Nous avons effectivement apporté
maison 14 drapeaux sur le bateau.
Les points forts
Est-ce qu'il pêche ici tous les jours,
donc il connaît le climat.
Je viens ici quatre jours, une fois par an.
Alors que se passe-t-il
là-bas, je ne sais pas.
Tu compte sur lui
savoir où sont les poissons,
quels appâts ils prennent,
quels leurres ils prennent,
quelle technique pêcher, et en gros,
vous venez ici et vous comptez sur eux.
Le plus gros poisson jamais pêché au Kenya
est un marlin bleu de 1 247 livres
attrapé par un pêcheur allemand
sur Neptune d'Angus Paul en 1997.
-J'ai été skipper professionnel
depuis je pense 19 ans maintenant,
mais j'ai pêché toute ma vie,
parce que mon père a commencé
pêcher ici il y a de nombreuses années
et j'avais grandi en pêchant.
Nous découvrons de nouveaux domaines,
nous explorons de nouveaux endroits,
Banques du nord du Kenya.
Ces cinq dernières années, nous venons de découvrir
les banques du nord du Kenya.
La pêche au bec large aussi,
vient juste d'être découvert
et le Kenya est l'un des meilleurs endroits
dans le monde maintenant pour l'espadon à bec large.
Donc ça devient plus fort
et de plus en plus fort et de mieux en mieux.
-Quelle est votre relation
avec des pêcheurs locaux ?
-Nous avons une bonne relation
avec les pêcheurs locaux,
dans la mesure où nous les aidons.
Nous les aidons
avec tous les vieux couchés sur les bobines.
Nous avons souvent dû partir
sortir la nuit pour les chercher
s'ils ont perdu ou des choses comme ça.
Nous avons de bonnes relations avec eux,
parce que j'ai été élevé avec eux.
J'ai été ici toute ma vie.
J'ai été élevé avec eux.
Oui, je les connais tous.
C'est une bonne relation.
Voile ou moteur, ligne ou filet,
traditionnel
ou des équipements de communication de haute technologie,
la pêche est toujours la pêche.
Pêcheurs sportifs et pêcheurs locaux
partager les mêmes méthodes,
types d'appâts et de leurres pour attraper du poisson.
La vraie différence est dans la taille
et la qualité des bateaux
et le matériel qu'ils utilisent.
-Que pensez-vous de la pêche au gros
avec les gros bateaux à moteur
par rapport aux techniques
qui sont utilisés par les pêcheurs locaux ?
-Je pense que c'est des chevaux pour les cours.
Si vous imaginez le marlin de 800 livres
qui a été attrapé l'autre nuit,
si tu avais attrapé
que sur un très petit bateau,
tu serais probablement quelque part
au large des côtes de l'Inde maintenant,
qui ressemble un peu à Old Man of the Sea.
Ernest Hemingway
a écrit quelque chose à ce sujet,
être traîné autour de l'océan
pour quelques jours.
Je pense que si tu y vas sérieusement
pour s'attaquer aux gros poissons,
il faut partir avec un bateau sérieux,
et les bateaux qui sont fournis vers le bas
ici peuvent tous manipuler de très bons poissons.
De mars à août,
La pêche au gros au Kenya
s'arrête faute de clients,
même si la saison est encore ouverte
et il y a beaucoup de poissons.
Pendant la haute saison,
les pêcheurs au gros viennent d'Allemagne,
les Pays-Bas, le Royaume-Uni,
Afrique du Sud ou Zimbabwe,
en compétition chaque week-end
dans de nombreux tournois.
Les compétitions ont lieu une semaine à Watamu
et une semaine à Malindi,
où ce marlin de 98 livres
a été comptabilisé.
La plus grande compétition
de la saison a lieu à Kilifi.
Cette année,
pas moins de 37 bateaux sont en compétition
de droite le long de la côte
de Mombasa à Malindi.
La majorité des skippers
sont anglais et kenyans.
Quelques-uns viennent d'Italie,
Allemagne et Afrique du Sud.
Kenyans ou étrangers,
ça ne fait pas de différance.
C'est l'événement qui compte.
Bien que la pêche sportive s'arrête en mars,
pêche traditionnelle
continue toute l'année.
Sauf pour les zones côtières près de l'île de Pate
et les villes de Lamu et Mombasa,
les stocks de poissons sont encore abondants au Kenya.
Des parcs nationaux marins ont été créés
à Kiunga, Malindi, Watamu et Pemba
pour assurer la protection
et la reproduction de nombreuses espèces
et des récifs coralliens.
Activités de pêche au Kenya
restent encore à petite échelle.
Cela explique pourquoi tant de poissons
sont capables d'atteindre une taille aussi remarquable.